derrière la crise sanitaire les
conséquences sociales avec des recherche
de boucs émissaires coup d'envoi cet
après midi à partie à paris du procès de
cinq personnes accusées d' appelé sur
les réseaux sociaux à la haine contre la
communauté chinoise accusé d'être à
l'origine de la propagation du
coronavirus on retrouve tout de suite
la 17e chambre du tribunal judiciaire de
paris
katia pique nique à katia comment ce
procès est il perçu et bien grégory
c'est un procès que d'aucuns qualifient
d'historique pour sa rapidité et aussi
peut-être parce qu'il marque la fin de
l'impunité en ligne alors que s'est il
passé bien des l'annoncent dur
confinement le 28 octobre 2020 une
flambée de message à caractère raciste
avait fleuri sur les réseaux sociaux des
appels au meurtre à la violence hors je
vais vous en citer quelques-uns
j'appelle tous mes revenus 91-92 etc
agressé chaque chinois qu'ils croiseront
dans la rue ou encore des appels à tabac
c'est ce qu'ils font langue vivante 2
chinois des centaines de messages en
tout alors les associations antiracistes
ont déposé des plaintes et ensuite le
parquet de paris très rapidement a
ouvert une enquête faut évidemment
rappelé que ce procès se déroule dans un
contexte de prise de conscience du
racisme anti asiatique dans le monde
inde où les récentes mobilisations aux
états unis est ici aussi il ait eu une
mobilisation juste avant le début du
procès à côté du tribunal vous propose
d'écouter les militants rassemblés
aujourd'hui il ya une vraie prise de
conscience de tous les partis politiques
de l'état de la justice qui en fait
entre l'appel allen fin octobre et
aujourd'hui l'ouverture de l'audience
contre les individus currin plein toute
la communauté asiatique de france a
agressé il ya eu quatre morts
aujourd'hui je suis fier de la justice
française qu'elle est très très vite
pour dire stop à ce qu'elle est vraiment
une ligne rouge a été franchie pour moi
je pense qu'il a été banalisée depuis
des années et qu'aujourd'hui on le met à
la lumière du jour comme aujourd'hui
pour pour sensibiliser non par les
asiatiques mais l'ensemble de la
population et que pour dire que votre
tweet un semblable peut devenir
dangereux nous avons des remontées moi
je suis élu à mieux rodé depuis est la
crise du colis de 19 nombreuses femmes
noires muriautin les rétines d'origine
asiatique m'ont fait remonter le fait
d'avoir été victime de justement de
stigmatisation d'attac complètement
infondées basé sur des fantasmes et donc
il disait être très très peinés et même
avoir peur et voilà pouvoir les miltants
grégory et nous avons nous en diront
plus sur le procès qui vient de démarrer
tout à l'heure merci catch un pique
nique en direct donc du palais de
justice de paris